c'est l'autre ministre écologiste du
gouvernement pascal canfin l invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous l'autre ministre avec
cécile duflot bien sûr ma sixième le
dossier le oui le deuxième le second
même si vous êtes plus discret peut-être
trop discret je ne sais pas on en
parlera au cours de cette émission même
si en tous les cas cette semaine vous
présentez votre premier projet de loi
sur la solidarité internationale se sera
donc mercredi au conseil des ministres
pascal canfin vous avez en charge donc
l'aide au développement en direction de
l'afrique notamment et vous nous direz
dans un instant si vous êtes totalement
à l'aise avec l'intervention en
centrafrique qui a lieu en ce moment
même avec deborah claude de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire comme
chaque semaine avec dailymotion eh bien
nous évoquons la place des verts aux
gouvernements des deux ministres
d'europe écologie les verts l'un des
débats internes qui agite votre
formation et puis vous aurez l'occasion
de répondre aux questions plus
personnelles de perrine tarneaud à la
fin de cette émission pour faire plus
ample connaissance on évoque d'abord
l'hommage mondial à nelson mandela avec
la présence des dirigeants du monde
entier et puis pour les français
peut-être une image qui marquera bien
sûr c'est celle ci c'est françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy côte à côte
dans le stade de soweto que vous inspire
cette photo
écoutez nelson mandela a été capable de
rapprocher des éléments de son peuple
qui s'étaient combattus pendant des
années et donc le fait que même décédé
il puisse se faire rapprocher deux
hommes qui se sont combattus pour la
présidence de la république
c'est encore un message post mortem de
fédération et je crois que nous pouvons
le saluer comme je salue le geste du
président de la république françois
hollande qui a été d'inviter son
prédécesseur à cet événement on a
entendu jean pierre raffarin dire que
c'était une marque de courtoisie tardy
20 franchement s'il ya bien un jour où
on peut s'abstenir de polémiquer je
crois que c'est un jour où on a un
hommage mondial
de la reconnaissance de l'action d'un
essaim manders vous dites ces deux
hommes se sont combattus en parle
toujours de françois l'ordre nicolas
sarkozy vous savez vous imaginez que
vous êtes plus que j'avais encore la
demande est là encore se livrer bataille
éventuellement en 2017 un scénario
complètement impossible chacun de l'en
tête alors on parle de l'opération 100
garris donc de sécurisation de la
centrafrique opération qui a lancé
depuis quelques jours avec la perte est
las de deux soldats français tués lors
d'un accrochage assez violent
semble-t-il et françois hollande fait
une courte escale ce mardi soir à bangui
comment est ce que vous voyez le chef de
l'état dans ses différentes missions en
afrique au centre a fait bien sûr au
mali au 19 djihadistes ont été tués ce
mardi par l'armée française en
humanitaire en rempart contre
l'islamisme non je pense qu'il faut pas
faire des grandes généralités ce qu'il
faut c'est regarder que fait que nous
sommes en train de tourner la page de ce
que l'on a appelé la françafrique que
l'on soit au mali que l'on soit en
centrafrique nous intervenons dans le
cadre de résolutions des nations unies
en soutien à des forces africaines il y
a aujourd'hui près de 4000 soldats
africains sur place en centrafrique et
donc nous faisons extrêmement attention
nous sommes très attentifs au respect de
cette légalité internationale et
regardez ce que faisait la france il y a
justement une trentaine d'années dans
les années 70 dans ce même pays la
centrafrique et comparer avec ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui et vous verrez
le chemin extraordinaire que nous avons
parcouru et aujourd'hui nous sommes bien
dans la fin de ce que nous avons appelé
à gauche la françafrique et c'est un
motif de fierté que ce soit au mali ou
en centrafrique d'être en responsabilité
pour sauver des vies pour sauver des
pays qui sont en train de tomber de
sombrer dans le chaos et en même temps
de le faire comme je dirais bras armé
opérateurs du monde entier de la
communauté internationale je rappelle
que 15 pays sur 15 du conseil de
sécurité dont quatre totalité
l'unanimité cet internat aux dites donc
c'est en rup c'était la rupture avec la
centrafrique les jours et fric avec la
françafrique qui a toujours réclamé la
gauche mais regardez aujourd'hui par
exemple les communistes michelle
demessine au sénat dénonce elle une
ingérence qui sert dit-elle nos propres
intérêts et il s'agirait quand on écoute
madame de médecine de reprendre la main
sur les intérêts économiques et
stratégiques de la france au
centrafrique dans lequel elle parle
toujours de françafrique la centrafrique
c'est un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde et si nous sommes les seuls à
intervenir aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
que c'est plutôt parce que il n'ya pas
beaucoup d'intérêt économique justement
à y aller il ya en revanche des valeurs
et ces débats ces valeurs nous les
défendons et nous les défendons quelque
part au nom de l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale qui nous ment
date pour le faire sur le plan de la
sécurité ensuite notre équation c'était
vrai au mali c'est vrai en centrafrique
c'est pas de développement sans sécurité
mais pas de sécurité dans la durée sans
développement c'est pour ça que moi en
tant que ministre du développement je
suis déjà en train de regarder avec
l'union européenne dont on dit qu'elle
est aux abonnés absents elle a déjà
moins pas sur le plan militaire vous
avez raison sur le plan de l'aide
humanitaire il ya déjà eu 50 millions
d'euros sur le plan du financement des
forces africaines qui nous accompagnent
il y a déjà eu aussi un financement
européen et maintenant va commencer le
temps du développement économique du
processus électoral donc la
reconstitution des fichiers de l'état
civil pour permettre le plus rapidement
possible au processus électoral des
élections démocratiques
je crois sincèrement que il fut un temps
où la france
empêcher qu'il y ait des élections
démocratiques mais et aider des gens à
la place d'autres en responsabilité dans
les pays africains ce temps est
totalement révolu puisque nous poussons
mais au contraire nous tous on nous
l'avons fait au mali et nous poussons au
centrafrique pour qu'il y ait justement
le plus rapidement possible des
élections
quelle meilleure preuve quelle meilleure
démonstration du fait que nous sommes
vraiment passés à autre chose et c'est
aussi parce que c'est une nouvelle
génération qui en responsabilité je
l'incarnent ce qui concerne la politique
de développement c'est la même chose
pour françois hollande c'est la même
chose pour beaucoup deux dirigeants
africains qui était cette semaine ce
week end à paris pour le sommet de
l'elysée qui sont tournés vers l'avenir
et plus vers le passant peut
s'interroger quand même aussi sur
l'objectif politique de la france dans
cette opération sans garris puisque
françois hollande vous utilisent
peut-être à ses côtés lors du sommet de
l'elysée justement il a dit qu'il
s'agissait quand même aussi de renverser
le président jo tibia parce qu'il dit là
il a dit la critique et il a dit qu'il
était responsable et qu'il fallait le
remplacer il pouvait pas continuer il ya
eu un coup d'état
ce coup d'état ensuite a fait l'objet
d'une critique internationale de la
communauté la france y est associée donc
il n'y a aucune raison de reconnaître
tout d'un coup
cette autorité comme légitime en général
ce n'est pas une parole spécifique de la
france paroles unanime de la communauté
internationale
ce coup et a ensuite s'est transformé en
une quasi guerre civile c'est ça qui a
fait que la france a obtenu un mandat et
une résolution des nations unies pour
rétablir l'ordre et ensuite ce n'est pas
pour conserver un régime qui est issu
d'un coup d'état ça c'était le passé
aujourd'hui c'est de d'organiser avec la
communauté internationale des élections
libres le plus rapidement quand même
parce que la france a un plan b par
exemple politique
c'était dans le pays mais est-ce police
votre question oui cedex ordinaire
pourquoi ce
pourquoi ce serait à nous d'avoir un
plan b politique
monsieur ou madame b pas du tout fait ce
soir ça ne se passe pas comme ça comme
ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça au mali
puisque vous en conviendrez il ya eu des
élections démocratiques avec une
participation historique au mali est un
président a été fier de l'armée
française je suis fier et l'armée
française et de l'action générale de la
france avec cette nouvelle page que nous
sommes en train d'écrire en afrique est
ce que vous craignez les risques
d'enlisement ce sont des réserves par
exemple qui sont émises au sein de votre
parti politique qui soutient cette
initiative et qui pointe les risques
verisk vous savez quand on fait quelques
enchaînements les nôtres fait quelque
chose en politique et je pense que c'est
vrai dans la vie on prend des risques
bon ça c'est la réalité les risques la
question c'est de les maîtriser et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes très attentifs à
ce que nous ne soyons pas seule il y a d
ores et déjà 4000 soldats africains il y
a le soutien logistique d'un certain
nombre de pays africains et c'est pour
ça que nous avons
c'est pour ça que nous avons mobilisé la
communauté internationale pour que dès
que possible nous puissions passer la
main à un régime sous le cadre des
nations unies de façon à ce que nous
soyons pas nous en permanence en
première ligne nous prenons nos
responsabilités
si nous ne l'avions pas fait il y aurait
peut-être eu des dizaines de milliers de
morts en centrafrique et vous seriez le
premier à me dire mais qu'est ce qu'a
fait la france où était françois
hollande bien sûr nous avons pris nos
responsabilités
maintenant encore une fois l'enjeu c'est
une fois que la situation sécuritaire
est rétabli c'est de passer à la phase
électorale démocratique et du retour des
services publics de la santé de
l'éducation de l'eau l'énergie ça c'est
ma responsabilité avec la communauté
internationale et le gouvernement de
centre afrique parce qu'il s'agit pas de
construire des systèmes parallèles il
s'agit de renforcer l'état de
centrafrique parce que s'il n'y a pas
d'état il n'y aura jamais de
développement et donc jamais de sécurit
mais vous savez qu'en parallèle de ce
développement que vous avez bloqué à
juste titre évidemment pascal canfin il
ya aussi l'aide que la france de
t'apporter sur le plan militaire pour
que pour qu'il y ait une armée africaine
des armées africaines pour que ces pays
puissent se défendre mais ça vous l'avez
vous l'approuvez aussi en bien
évidemment c'était tournage à loyer
militairement cpi c'était tout l'objet
du sommet de l'elysée où nous avons
réuni presque la totalité des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement africains
autour d'un objectif principal qui est
de voir avec eux comment nous pouvons
mettre en place une force d'intervention
rapide
piloté par l'union africaine sous
l'égide de l'union africaine avec désolé
quand même pour l'afrique assure quand
même sa sécurité vous voyez bien qu'on
ait sérieusement et définitivement en
train d'écrire une nouvelle nouvelle
page on tourne la page de la
françafrique vous le répéter et on l'a
dit à l'assemblée il a été hué dans les
rangs de la droite oui la france est
peut-être que ça leur pose un problème
et ça vous pouvez la nation je sais pas
moi sur la droite se met à huer le fait
qu'on fasse un énorme progrès
démocratiques dans la gestion de notre
relation avec l'afrique c'est vraiment
leur problème et si vous voulez me faire
dire que claude guéant il y a quelques
mois lorsqu'il était en responsabilité
avec nicolas sarkozy incarné précisément
les pires pratiques et les pires
méthodes de la françafrique je vous le
dis avec plaisir d'accord moi je vais
rien vous faire dire qu'on va plus que
vous dites et je la transmets à claude
guéant
tout ça coûte cher on l'a dit aux
finances de l'état il ya budget qui est
dédié ses opérations extérieures est ce
qu'il faut faire des économies dans le
budget de la défense comme le suggère
par exemple jean vincent placé
abandonner une partie de notre
dissuasion nucléaire moi je vais vous
dire quelle est la position des
écologistes et donc quelle est ma
position
dont j'ai bien conscience qu'elle n'est
pas majoritaire au sein du gouvernement
l'armée en tant qu'écologiste excite
l'univers là non pas du tout enfin pas
majoritaires au sein des verts
majoritaires au sein du gouvernement
nous les écologistes quelles que soient
les responsabilités que nous occupons
dans ce parti nous sommes unis pour dire
la menace stratégique a changé et donc
le fait d'avoir de mettre autant de
moyens financiers autant de moyens
budgétaires pour avoir une bombe
atomique l'arme nucléaire civil nous
semble disproportionné l'arme nucléaire
militaire pardon il me semble
disproportionné
c'est autre chose tout à fait parce que
la menace a changé vous savez c'est pas
en envoyant pendant qu'à une rumba
tellement d'abandon va régler la
question d'al qaïda au maghreb on voit
bien que les groupes sont très
différents que les menaces sont très
différentes
on a besoin d'opération de capacités de
projection pour faire exactement ce que
nous sommes en train de faire en
centrafrique est ce que nous avons fait
au mali et pour avoir ses moyens faut-il
encore pouvoir tailler ailleurs donc et
c'est pour ça que nous sommes
extrêmement cohérent puisque nous disons
oui à ces moyens supplémentaires comme
nous sommes dans un cadre budgétaire
contraint couper ailleurs coupées ou
dans l'armement civil nucléaire dont
nous pensons qu'il n'est plus adapté à
la menace stratégique nous l'avons
toujours pensé à l'époque du bloc
soviétique mais aujourd'hui et beaucoup
de militaires sont sur cette ligne là
officiellement ou officieusement puisque
militaires ne peuvent pas forcément
s'exprimer de manière publique et je
peux vous dire que ce débat en interne
de l'armée il existe parce qu'on voit
bien que là où la france est sollicitée
là où il ya les réelles menaces ça n'a
rien à voir avec le fait d'être au
pouvoir a varié sur un bouton et envoyée
c'est une bombe atomique nord sachets la
position se passer des écologistes de
notre diffuseur toutes les spéciales is
back scud pour savoir s'il sera bien
sous marins ou d'autres peu importe très
bien c'est la question de principe c'est
n'est pas je le redis encore sonné je le
sais très bien pas la position
majoritaire au sein du gouvernement
c'est toujours été l'apanage des
écologistes jeu là des frères et donc
c'est la complexité des écologistes au
sein du gouvernement va en parler mais
quand et où des contradictions ou des
difficultés à suivre la démarche parfois
on est mal de jeux majoritaire parfois
en évidence allez on va évoquer la
marche du gouvernement justement avec
dit-on un premier ministre qui a repris
la main en lançant vous le savez la
remise à plat de la fiscalité plus
d'autorité aussi peut-être vis-à-vis des
verts on va en parler entre les quatre
débats relèvera claude de la fpf est
avec nous dans une minute pour vous
interroger donc sur votre expérience au
plus près de jean marc ayrault d'abord
le récit de françois rollin
jean marc ayrault à la main et compte
bien la garder sur la sellette tout près
d'être remplacé par françois hollande il
est passé à l'offensive
sa remise à plat de la fiscalité
un joli coup médiatique ministres et
parlementaires socialistes sont unanimes
un moyen de réaffirmer son autorité pour
quelques mois est de ressouder la
majorité parlementaire le groupe
socialiste toujours été très unie
derrière le le premier ministre et cette
initiative qui correspond à l'engagement
de campagne du président de la
république eh bien nous allons y
travailler faire des propositions sauf
que ce coup d'éclat s'est fait aux
dépens de deux ministres directement
concernés pierre moscovici et bernard
cazeneuve qui ont été mis devant le fait
accompli eux qui tentait il y encore
quelques semaines d'enterrer la promesse
de françois hollande 'l'annonce le
premier ministre l'a fait en une des
échos même françois hollande a été pris
de court prévenus au dernier moment et
par sms ces conseillers grogne il nous a
fait un bébé dans le dos répète il à qui
veut l'entendre pour certains ministres
il s'agit d'un coup de canif dans la
cohésion gouvernementale est un cadeau
empoisonné
il ya ceux qui espèrent succéder à
jean-marc ayrault qu'ils disent merci
pour le paquet de merde je cite un seul
à et puis au bout de quelques jours il
ya quand même eu un sentiment diffus
chez tout le monde et notamment chez les
ministres de se dire ok c'est un bon
coup politique en tout cas maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça parce que
c'est quand même
une référence sacrément compliqué à
mettre en application les grandes lignes
de cette réforme seront distillées d'ici
juillet et s'étaleront sur deux
quinquennats explique matignon un moyen
de s'inscrire dans le temps et de
conserver davantage la politique c'est
le mouvement aime à dire jean marc
ayrault et pour l'instant c'est lui qui
mène la danse
d'abord à vos questions à pascal canfin
sur le gouvernement sur les
gouvernements autre sujet c'est pas
compliqué apparemment c'est ce que vous
étiez en train de dire mais ce week-end
mahut arnaud montebourg et le remarquer
aux quêtes et en chine voilà vrp de le p
r et on s'est dit tiens finalement
serment borloo ministre de l'écologie là
il à dire moi je crois que c'était
philippe martin c'est qui a misé les
collections vous voyez bien c'est donc
philippe martin et arnaud montebourg a
dit ce ne sont pas les écologistes qui
donne la sur la politique énergétique
vous savez c'est vrai qui donne le la
c'est le président de la république et
c'est pas non plus arnaud montebourg et
qu'est ce qu'il a dit le président de la
république il a dit combien de fois et
pendant la campagne et depuis qu'il est
président la république qu'il y aura une
réduction de la part du nucléaire de 75
80 % aujourd'hui à 50% de la production
d'électricité c'est un élément clé du
contrat de gouvernement que nous avons
passé et personne n'y croyait sonne le
remet en cause ni le président de la
république qui a même eu l'occasion de
le redire ni le premier ministre qui l'a
dit lui-même lui même en chine et donc
moi je ne suis pas là pour polémiquer je
suis pas là pour polémiquer
alors émis des centres disiez vous
disiez en introduction que j'étais
discret problème vous avez dit très
discret mais peut-être que les français
en ont marre en ont marre des couacs en
ont marre des polémiques parce qu'il ce
qu'ils veulent c'est des résultats est
ce qu'on est en train de faire au mali
ce qu'on est en train de faire en
centrafrique dont j'ai partie la
responsabilité
je crois que ça ça démontre que derrière
les polémiques derrière la mousse il ya
des résultats et je crois que au final
c'est ça que les français regarderont et
pas les petites vaches à lait petit pot
limit il est né péché
c'est ça vous prendra quand même
regarder qui n'intervient sur nos dos et
sur les dossiers l'écologie de sa
primaire socialiste grande partie de sa
primaire quand il était candidat face à
françois hollande de la première
socialiste sur des thèmes écolos c'était
le plus écologiste des candidats à la
primaire socialiste et puis et puis il a
retourné ses positions pour des raisons
qui lui appartiennent je n'ai pas à les
commenter et maintenant c'est devenu le
héros et art de tous les lobbys le
nucléaire les gaz de schiste
l'automobile c'est giresse et voilà
c'est une réalité nous nous faisons avec
mais attendez s'ils voulaient
interviewer monsieur montebourg demande
un bourg de villepin connaissait mais
moi je n'ai encore moi j'ai ma cohérence
et nous on a notre cohérence wayne
rooney ont dit au gouvernement ce que
nous disions avant et là encore dans la
durée c'est ce que les français
regardent recherche et je pense après si
tu regarde aussi vous avez eu un accord
avec le ps est-ce que ça progresse les
dossiers depuis 18 mois les écolos vous
êtes content gouvernement les dossiers
avancent la fiscalité écologique ça
avance le diesel nous avions
déçu dans vos rangs qu'un pion les gaz
de schiste prononce celui là on pourra
revenir sur la fiscalité ensuite sur les
gaz de schiste est ce que vous diriez
que c'est une victoire des écologistes
la situation actuelle je dis que c'est
assez compliqué parce que visiblement il
ya eu il ya eu des permis ils sont
arrivés en corse et philippe martin du
tout il les a c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire depuis les visions en
tout cas d'un flottement tous les
arbitrages tous les arbitrages alors ne
regardez pas les petites phrases les
déclarations que c'est m regardez les
décisions les décisions qui sont prises
au lit tous les arbitrages qui ont été
pris depuis 18 mois y compris les tout
derniers sur les gaz de schiste et les
fameux permis que vous venez d'évoquer
vont tous dans le même sens c'est à dire
que la france n'aura pas recours à cette
technologie tout simplement parce que à
la différence des états unis les etats
unis c'est un pays vide c'est-à-dire que
quand vous faites des gaz de schiste
dans les dakota du nord je pas si vous
êtes déjà allé un jour dans le
quaterback total dix noms
le temps il ya de très bonnes raisons de
ne pas y aller parce que justin est rien
et donc vous pouvez effectivement forêt
des centaines de milliers des centaines
de milliers de puits où sont les
gisements sont les gisements mais c'est
la position toutes les semaines sur le
site
c'est une victoire des écologistes ont
arrêté de le mettre dans la liste des
flous des incertitudes ou erreurs que je
ne sais quoi mais là où nous alors nous
avions fixé trois points principaux dans
notre
revendication quelque sorte au moment du
débat budgétaire le projet de loi de
finances il y avait le budget de l'ademe
l' agence de la maîtrise de l'énergie
qui éjacule colts sans que le bras armé
de l'état pour faire des économies
d'énergie ce ce budget ce budget qui
avait été effectivement largement amputé
à un moment donné est remonté donc nous
avons gagné le deuxième c'était la
fiscalité écologique ce qu'on appelle la
contribution climat énergie là où
nicolas sarkozy s'était cassé les dents
en quelque sorte auparavant là où même à
un moment donné lionel jospin avait
essayé mais sans succès nous avons
réussi à introduire enfin une dose de
fiscalité écologique dans notre système
fiscal on reparlera peut-être de la
réforme de la fiscalité que les
déclarations de jean marc ayrault
récemment donc nous avons réussi nous
est nous sommes aujourd'hui le 25e et
assure 28 dans l'union européenne pour
concernant la part de la fiscalité qui
taxe les pollutions sur la totalité des
impôts
troisième point non le troisième nous
avons perdu trois jeux nous avons perdu
à voyez quand on gagne le diesel le
disais nous nous étions favorables et
nous le sommes toujours à le au fait que
la fiscalité sur le diesel augmente tout
simplement parce que et c'est encore été
reconnus très récemment paru aujourd'hui
ou hier que l'étude les parties s'est
produit cancérigène notoire nous sommes
dans la cité évidemment nous sommes
relations alors donc juste moi bus ou
une phrase nous sommes dans la situation
où nous subventionnons hauteur de 8
milliards d'euros par an un produit
cancérigène notoire est-ce qu'on peut
être amené à se poser la question est de
dire ok c'était un choix du passé
organisons la transition va pas couper
demain mais organisons la transition en
trois ans quatre ans cinq ans six ans
pour sortir de cette situation absurde
et on a perdu donc c'est un combat que
nous remettrons dans les mois prochains
oui c'est ça la politique du personnel
c'est simple la politique c'est parfois
on gagne parfois on perd quand on décide
de faire la politique c'est qu'on est
sur le terrain d'accord pour marquer des
buts on pourrait très bien regarder ça
dans les tribunes comme jean luc
mélenchon en disant bien sûr
jean luc mélenchon l'a fait le choix de
ne pas être au gouvernement pour autant
qu'on lui aurait proposé il est donc
dans les tribunes quelle quelle victoire
at il remporté depuis les tribunes
depuis 18 mois aucune nous nous pouvons
faire la liste des victoires que nous
avons remportés même si je ne vous dirai
jamais que c'est suffisant bien
évidemment parce que je veux on veut
toujours toujours plus c'est normal
c'est notre notre conviction c'est notre
engagement en revanche nous avons
remporté des victoires importantes qui
justifie notre présence au gouvernement
et d'ailleurs la majorité des françaises
âgées de 50 ans et des batailles il faut
rester sur le long terme toujours donc
on ne part jamais quoi vous si parce
qu'à un moment on peut très bien dit
imaginons que les trois points que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le budget la
fiscalité écologique et le diesel nous
ayons perdu sur les 3 et imaginons que
nous perdions un jour sur les gaz de
schiste cela voudrait dire quoi ça
voudrait dire qu'il n'ya plus d'ambition
de transformation écologique de notre
modèle économique et donc à ce moment là
nous en tirerions les conséquences mais
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui si on
peut passer maintenant la situation de
votre parti donc vous apparemment vous
vous sentez bien
un moment où il ya un ministre du
redressement productif qui est aussi
ministre de l'écologie vous avez vous
vous comptabilisez jeu c'est le mauvais
ministres du redressement productif donc
c'est parti
je pas sûr que ça passionne énormément
les concernés on entend quand même le
patron des sénateurs verts dire que
arnaud montebourg c'est l'échec l'échec
au gouvernement on peut passer aux tirs
un gouvernement comme ça faire le tri
dans les milices viennent aussi de votre
parti bien sûr et je pense qu'il ya une
forme d'immaturité à alimenter en
permanence la polémique parce que encore
une fois ce n'est pas ce que les
français veulent les manuels et de
cohésion ils ne nous ont pas aidés je
crois que ma y compris ils ne nous ont
pas aidés non mais bien quand c'est
exposé les français ne nous ont pas élus
pour ce genre de polémiques stériles en
revanche je restais sur arnaud
montebourg gérer sur le podium asturies
c'est qu'ils savent également vincent
placé pour vous voilà je vais rester sur
était de stroom grognon
grognon franchement alors donc je vais
rester sur l'appui aux ministres du
redressement productif
il y a quelques semaines le arnaud
montebourg a demandé un cabinet
international de dire qu'elle est là
quelle est la stratégie industrielle que
la france doit mener filière par filière
quels sont les grands actifs
stratégiques de la france en se
projetant dans les 10 ou 15 prochaines
années le coeur de notre compétitivité
de demain qu'est ce qu'il est ressorti
de cette étude fait par un cabinet
anglo-saxon commandé par arnaud
montebourg c'est que la moitié la moitié
des 34 filières d'avenir de l'industrie
française sont des filières d'industrie
verte la moitié dans le domaine de la
chimie le domaine de la théologie des
énergies etc là qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que même après que le
prisme que vous évoquez d'arnaud
montebourg disons anti écolo le résultat
c'est que la moitié la moitié des
filières et d'accords industriels
d'avenir de la france et l'écossé que
c'est ça qu'on doit des forêts mais est
ce que c'est ça qui va craquer
fonctionne notamment parce que quand
vous êtes fier de l'armée française en
centrafrique au mali est ce que vous
êtes fier aussi du combat que mène par
exemple il ya quelques jours encore le
premier ministre en chine pour y
construire de nouveau être de nouvelles
centrales si vous êtes fier là encore
sont très simples les choses sont pas
notés sent quand même auquel nous nous
ne sommes pas favorables à l'énergie
nucléaire ce soit dans le domaine
militaire mais dans le domaine civil
pourquoi parce qu'on l'a vu prenez
l'exemple de fukushima au japon plus de
deux ans après c'est toujours ingéré
ingérable il ya toujours des fuites
radioactives et le japon aujourd'hui est
condamné et condamné
à renoncer à la baisse de ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre parce qu'en fait
quand une centrale à un problème c'est
évidemment l'ensemble des centrales du
pays qui sont à mise à l'arrêt parce que
tout le monde a peur voilà donc j'ai
fait
écouter c'est pour ça que sur le
nucléaire sur le clair nos désaccords
sont connus et que le coeur de l'accord
politique que nous avons sur la question
énergétique c'est de passer de 75% à 50%
et ça nous allons le faire dans la
grande loi de transition énergétique pas
se représenter en 2014 si on peut
revenir un petit peu sur l écologie les
verts passons du gouvernement à votre
parti une nouvelle patronne qui a été
désigné il ya quelques semaines quelques
jours emmanuelle cosse quelle autonomie
elle va à voir comment ça va se passer
noël mamère est parti isabella d'arrêt
est parti tout le monde fuit un peu
élevé là mon impression que c'est laid
comme la bulle internet là c'est en
train d'éclater et il ya les élections
européennes au mois de juin
vous espérez faire confiance et ça c'est
beaucoup de questions
europe ecologie les verts est en train
d'exploser
je vais vous dire très sincèrement moi
je suis j'étais journaliste comme vous
avant je suis entré en politique un peu
exactement je suis entré en politique au
moment des européennes de 2009 et la
dynamique avec josé bové lenny
cohn-bendit eva joly
oui mais je ne pourrai madras action est
question je réponds que leur répondez
vite alors si la bulle explose alors
laissez-moi répondre donc je suis venu
pour cette dynamique là c'est ça qui m'a
intéressé je dois vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas satisfait
par la façon dont le parti fonctionne et
nous avons impérativement besoin de
retrouver la dynamique qui a fait notre
succès en 2009 tout simplement parce que
la crise environnementale la crise
écologique le changement climatique la
rareté des ressources l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie etc n'a évidemment pas
disparu et donc est ce que nous deux
être à la hauteur de ces enjeux c'est
pour ça que je ne veux pas faire de
polémique c'est pour ça que je veux être
en responsabilité pour changer les
choses et je pense que on ne peut pas
dire à nous sommes dans un nouveau monde
nous sommes en train de changer de monde
avec le changement climatique par
exemple et puis se contenter de
minuscules polémique picrocholines on a
une responsabilité et donc je suis ni
avec ça un nous ne sommes pas toujours à
la hauteur de ce que
les candidats pour les élections je suis
mauvais ce qui va être candidat j'ai dit
tout à fait je trouverais
inconcevable inconcevable que josé bové
ne soit pas désignée comme étant
candidat pour europe écologie aux
européennes alors que dans le même temps
nous le soutenons pour être un des deux
leaders de notre campagne avec une verre
allemande au niveau européen quelle
cohérence cela aurait-il évidemment
aucune c'est pour ça qu'il est impératif
tout simplement impératif que josé bové
et michèle rivasi d'ailleurs dans ce
choix est désigné comme candidat et ce
sera ce week end le conseil fait d'abord
avait beaucoup de choses à dire sur
votre parti bizarrement on n'est pas
pris la parole lors du récent congrès
adopte deux camps c'était le mutisme
total oui pourquoi je vous pose la
question parce que je ne suis pas
satisfait de la façon dont ça s'est
passé vous auriez pu l'exprimer elle je
le dis aujourd'hui une façon d'exprimer
une façon d'exprimer son mécontentement
c'est de ne rien dire voilà vous avez
été encore une fois plus explicite avec
nous ce soir pascal canfin revoir merci
merci d'abord à on va parler de vous
justement pascal canfin perrine tarneaud
arrive juste après c'est premiers
éléments qui ont été recueillis par
mounir souci il s'est habitué à être
photographié dans la cour de l'elysée
pourtant il y a quelques années pascal
canfin était de l'autre côté du cordon
avant d'entrer en politique le ministre
du développement était journaliste à
alternatives économiques
un magazine qui met en avant d'autres
modèles de croissance un bagage bien
utile pour la suite de son parcours
pascal sait ce que c'est qu'une
entreprise il sait ce que c'est que
parce qu'il voyait dans une note remise
comme la nôtre d'une coopérative vous
n'êtes pas journaliste
un saltimbanque qui s'occupe pas des
comptes vous regardez aussi si l'argent
rentre pascal est un vrai développeur en
même temps un développeur qui n'empêche
pas d'avoir des vraies convictions
militantes son engagement militant se
renforce à l'occasion des européennes de
2009 il profite de la vague écologiste
pour entrer au parlement
parrainée par eva joly et daniel cohn
bendit il se plonge dans les questions
financières et contribuer à la création
de faille non swatch un organisme qui
milite pour plus de contrôle de ce
secteur pascal canfin est un élément
très important dans notre groupe des
verts au parlement européen
et dans ce travail législatif il faut
des hommes et des femmes qui rentrent
pas ce que j'appelle moi le coeur du
réacteur c'est à dire des gens qui
comprennent réellement et finalement les
députés
capable d'entrer dans les coeurs des
réacteurs sont très peu nombreux
aujourd'hui installé au quai d'orsay au
sein d'un gouvernement socialiste son
périmètre d'intervention est restreint
mais il est au coeur du pouvoir une
participation qui fait sourire son
premier employeur en 1998 pascal canfin
a travaillé pour pierre larrouturou
l'économiste qui vient de créer son
parti pour rompre avec le ps se souvient
d'un bon élément qui ne voulaient pas
insulter l'avenir qu'on s'entendait
vraiment bien et en même temps il y
avait une petite tension sur quelle
distance en prenez par rapport au parti
socialiste parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait des lois fait 35 heures qui était
en discussion on était quelques uns et
dia que la loi sur les 35 heures était
que la méthode était mauvaise et que le
contenu était très ambigu et pascal
était un de ceux qui
vous voulez pas trop critiquer souvent
en retrait sur la photo ou à la tribune
le bruit circule qu'il souhaiterait
revenir à strasbourg à l'occasion des
prochaines européennes une envie qu eva
joly comprend parfaitement
lorsque honnête parlement européen c'est
la place aussi pour les visions pour les
visions de l'avenir et le fait de les
changer et je comprends que pascal
canfin et la nostalgie aussi de ce rôle
là à parler fait que d'être ministre est
une vie folle et que on est peut-être
aussi plus heureux comme député
aller plus loin dans notre portrait et
puis peut-être vos intentions futures
puisque la manifestation
bruxelles ou strasbourg est ce que vous
êtes tenté ce que vous avez envie de
retourner au parlement européen et donc
d'être candidat au mois de juin je ne
serai pas candidat aux élections
européennes
tout simplement parce que je ne suis pas
sur la liste qui va être désigné ce week
end au conseil fédéral j'ai fait le
choix de ne pas être candidat décision
c'est ma décision donc je vous dis je
c'est un choix qui est des remonte à
quelques quelques semaines maintenant
parce que en ile-de-france et pascal
durand et sans doute eva joly qui seront
candidats pour europe ecologie les verts
pourquoi ne pas avoir envie finalement
de retourner au parlement eva joly a
l'air de dire que finalement vous
vous faisait plus d'être plus utile au
parlement européen je vous avais demandé
demandé aujourd'hui aux ong qui se
battent pour les droits de l'homme en
afrique pour un nouveau modèle de
développement en afrique puisque je
m'occupe de l'aide publique au
développement qui concerne
essentiellement en afrique je pense
qu'elles pourront dire que cette action
est utile nous allons passer demain la
première loi la toute première loi de
l'histoire de la république sur la
solidarité internationale et le
développement cette politique qui
n'avait jamais fait l'objet d'un
contrôle démocratique parlementaire
parce qu'elle était issue on en parlait
au début de l'émission d'hier est de
l'histoire de la politique africaine de
la france
il n'y a jamais eu de projet de loi par
définition parce que c'était quelque
chose qui était je dirais opaque parce
qu'il fallait pouvoir le gérer au bon
vouloir des dirigeants est allongé dans
un but où les lois de finances
était le seul le budget c'était la seule
chose bien évidemment qui était votée
par le parlement il était une fois qu'on
peut regarder qu'en voix off je vais
finir avec hambourg je vais venir après
quand vous regardez le contenu la
qualité des risques et ce qui était fait
et concrètement dans ce budget de
l'argent c'est bien mais on en fait
quelque chose et bien alors c'était sous
les pas soumis au contrôle du parlement
donc nous allons faire c'est une grande
avancée démocratique maintenant puisque
vous dites que ça baisse vos moyens les
moyens nous avons mobilisé les
financements innovants la taxe sur les
transactions financières nous avons
augmenté la contribution de solidarité
sur les billets d'avion ce qui fait que
exactement créée par jacques chirac en
2006 et il faut lui rendre hommage ce
qui fait que la banlieue jetair la messe
du budget a été très largement compensé
par cette hausse là ce qui fait que au
final je le conteste pas il ya moins 100
millions d'euros sur la publique au
développement sur un budget total de
9,2 milliards donc on voit qu'on est sur
une baisse très relative et c'est un
choix politique c'est un choix politique
encore une fois on parler de fierté tout
à l'heure dont moi je suis fier et qui
est je crois utile pourquoi parce que
nous ne devons pas sacrifier notre aide
aux plus pauvres ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin pour vivre pour accéder aux
médicaments pour accéder à l'éducation
même même si nous avons nos propres
contraintes budgétaires donc vous n'êtes
pas le ministre de l'inutile comme un
pull titre et 1m de madère c'était bien
calculé c'était noir l'air totalement
polémique sans avoir vérifié ce qu'on
faisait et en plus c'était au début
c'était extraordinaire c'est au début
qualifiée d'inutile au début je pense
sincèrement et que 18 mois après
interroger les personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces questions interrogé
le million de français qui est soit
bénévole soit donateurs dans une
association de solidarité internationale
et qui fait vivre cette solidarité au
quotidien dans la société française je
pense que la plupart vous diront que ce
que nous faisons est utile efficace et
reconnu mais c'est vrai que vous faites
partie de ses membres du gouvernement
qui sont pour l'instant encore un peu
inconnu
mais qu'est-ce que vous
mais c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure moi si vous voulez la notoriété
pour la notoriété pour faire la dépêche
parce que j'aurais dit une grosse
polémique qui est super ça fait là ses
formes il ya une très grosse pour les
mineurs ça ne l'intéresse pas je suis
désolé je ne fais pas de la politique
pour ça et je crois que ce n'est
absolument pas ce que les français
attendent de la politique et je dirais
même plus que ce genre de polémiques
stériles qui rend alimente en permanence
le tuyau de l'information continue sa
déconnecte sa déconnecte les français de
la politique et moi pourquoi je fais de
la politique c'est justement pour servir
pour reconnecter les français pour
montrer l'utilité on parlait du
parlement européen en tout à l'heure
j'ai été le seul député le staff je suis
le seul à avoir interdit réussi à
interdire un produit financier en europe
puisque j'étais à la commission les
affaires financières le seul à avoir
interdit un produit financier en europe
depuis la crise financière de 2008-2009
le seul c'est moi qui l'ait mener ce
combat il ya comment est donc j'étais
pas efficace et je le
seul contre-pouvoir qui s'appelle find
swatch a en la finance il vaut mieux
est-ce que les français le savent
forcément manon à la deuxième fois vous
le répéter après le reportage mais alors
donc pascal canfin il vaut mieux être un
ministre inconnu des français que
détesté des français hauteur de 75%
comme ce sujet floracois vous faites
référence à la chagrine pour la ministre
du logement que vous avez sans doute
trouvé injuste vous savez ce qu'il faut
d'abord regarder c'est quand on est
responsable politique c'est ce que les
français qui sont sensibles à vos idées
donc les sympathisants europe écologie
les verts dans la société française ce
qu'ils se disent proches de nos idées
pensent de nous alors vous prenez ce
sondage compte quel est le pourcentage
puisque voulu vous devez le connaître
quel est le pourcentage des
sympathisants d'europe écologie les
verts qui a une bonne image de cécile
duflot et qui pensent que cécile duflot
incarne le jeu bien l'écologie
c'est 92% donc voyez peut-être que ça
baisse mais enfin on en est
promotion de ce
côté d'un sondage de la société
française 60 millions ensuite vous
parlez d'un parti et c'est un des
problèmes que nous avons et je le cache
pas c'est cette faiblesse
par partisane que nous avons
l'organisation collective notre
incapacité à travailler davantage en
collectif est une pierre dans notre
jardin et c'est pour ça que quand nous
faisons un congrès qui ne se passe pas
bien vous dis je ça m'énerve ça m'énerve
donc je préfère dans un dîner temps je
préfère dans un premier temps ne rien
dire et ensuite de construire parce que
j'aimerais qu'on la porte parce que je
vais m'asseoir autour ou là votre mii je
pense que l'écologie l'écologie la crise
écologique les enjeux écologiques du 21e
siècle mérite mieux parfois que la façon
dont certains écologistes se comporte
c'est triste mais c'est la réalité je
suis là pour essayer de la changer
michel évoqué pierre la route auront
donc avec qui vous avez travaillé on
vient de le voir dans le reportage il
vient de créer un nouveau parti la
nouvelle donne qui se veut une
alternative au parti socialiste alors il
vous invite à le rejoindre vous lui
répondez quoi ah bon je réponds que il a
été excellent il a été au parti
socialiste il a été chez nous c'est un
peu du comment dire du tourisme
partidaire du tourisme partisans pierre
larrouturou il a des idées mais son parc
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant mais
moi je pense qu'on a toujours besoin on
a toujours besoin d'innovation on a
toujours besoin de créativité sel on
n'est jamais assez créatif on est dans
un nouveau monde
ce nouveau monde c'est pas avec les
solutions d'hier en regardant dans le
rétroviseur qu'on va construire l'avenir
de la france et l'avenir de l'europe et
donc tous ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
prêts à mettre des nouvelles idées et
pierre larrouturou en fait partie dans
le débat public eh bien ils sont les
biens vous avez beaucoup milité pour la
tenue à paris en décembre 2015 du sommet
sur le climat qui va se tenir donc dans
un an en décembre 2001 un américain la
plus grande conférence internationale
que la france devait jamais oui dans
deux ans
on
la question alors alors la question à la
question
si vous voulez vous attendiez notre
possible et si vous serez encore au
gouvernement pour gérer vous semblez
qui le sait on a donc si vous croyez que
nous ont fait
n'était pas il ya trois ans j'étais pas
en responsabilité politique j'ai été élu
j'ai trois ans parlementaires européens
premier ministre est prêt dans la clique
ont demandé de venir au gouvernement on
verra de quoi l'avenir sera fait
liberté le projet jusqu'au bout en
décembre 2015 j'ai cette liberté est
extra ordinaire et extraordinaire
liberté c'est beau liberté
extraordinaire d'avoir fait ce que
beaucoup de responsables politiques font
dans une carrière toute une vie en trois
ans avant je faisais autre chose
peut-être un jour je fais autre chose
c'était liberté extraordinaire de me
dire je ne suis pas dépendant de la
politique la politique je la serre mais
je ne m'en sers pas et je crois que les
français apprécient ce genre de choses
pour autant qu'ils le connaissent vous
avez raison très bien mais cela ne sonne
ça ne ça ne dépend que de vous élever au
quant au sommet sur le climat c'est un
des plus grands rendez vous du
quinquennal de françois hollande s'est
dit par le président la république
lui-même par laurent fabius est
effectivement le fait d'en avoir la
responsabilité
c'est un enjeu majeur et si nous
arrivons à trouver à paris un accord
international le premier accord
international sur le climat qui avait
échoué à copenhague j'aurais été
j'aurais été très utile et le phare
lille désir voilà mais il le faut la
planète se réchauffe et ce qu' il est
difficile d'exister sa dernière question
sur ce thème là sauf à la toute dernière
question d'ailleurs à côté de laurent
fabius c'est laurent fabius
sincèrement c'est un c'est un homme
d'état est ce que je partage avec lui on
a parfois en désaccord très largement
d'accord sur la politique africaine sur
le nucléaire par exemple mais par contre
sur la politique africaine on est
parfaitement d'accord et ce que je
partage avec lui je pense c'est le sens
de l'état merci beaucoup d'avoir est
avec nous cette semaine pascal canfin
merci père et si la semaine prochaine
c'est vincent peillon le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui sera notre
invité à très vite